[Music]
this morning on the dish the thai
restaurant the top
esquire's list of the best new
restaurants of 2020.
kalyan was opened by a former flight
attendant who was retired for nine years
before she returned to her long time
dream noc
suntarenin wants to change the
widespread perception of thai food
as quick and easy takeout by opening a
thai restaurant focused on fine dining
we were more than ready for the
experience
this looks incredible yeah the look is
everything
and i mean that's the first impression
when you see it it's build your appetite
where do we start we start from the
appetizer
knock suntorn and kick things off with
what might be the most colorful dish
we've ever seen including tapioca
dumplings with a mushroom
sweet radish and peanut filling and
flower shaped dumplings with
chicken and sweet radish inside it's a
bird dumpling it's a bird it's a bird my
name is nocus mean bird so this is my
dumpling it takes hours to make these
completely by hand
but it's well worth it
so fresh my food is built around memory
of my childhood
so my grandmother she always loved to
cook the little appetizer for me when
she came i came back from school
santa reynon's grandmother never shared
any of those old recipes
so she relies on the memories of the
taste and smell she experienced growing
up
in thailand so this dish is come from
the
old capital of thailand in ayutthaya
that's very close to bangkok
that includes this spicy and sour
lemongrass soup with baramundi
mushrooms and these jumbo river prawns
okay so i break the head off you break
the head off then you will find
the part in the head is tomales
that's like the brain or the fatty part
you can scrape it
back into the bowl yes
oh yeah that's the best part i love it i
love it
it's like squeezing out the best
condiment ever exactly and it's so
creamy it's add a very good flavor and
good consistency into the broth
some people think you eat thai food with
chopsticks you don't
no we don't cinternon's take on
traditional thai dishes are a unique
blend of buddhist culture
indian style curries and crucially south
american chilies
originally brought to the region by
portuguese missionaries in the late
sixteen hundreds their intensity is
matched only
by centurion's personality heat
is something that thai dishes are famous
for and you're famous
for not backing off on that heat you
don't make less spicy dishes
no i never back off from anything not
just only food
i like that for more than 20 years
sincerandon worked as a flight attendant
for kuwait airways
than thai airways have you had a fresh
river prawn before
no i don't think so she was retired for
nine years before opening
kalaya in philadelphia in 2019
a nearby thai market followed last year
one thing that
i think sometimes intimidates people
about thai food especially really
authentic thai food like this
is that it's not it's not simple it's
it's complicated
you know that's how you could look at it
but the other
way that you could look at is like this
is the way of life this is the culture
well that's one of the things i love
about your cooking is that you don't
some people try to
americanize their food and you don't you
embrace
where you came from because i think you
know when i moved to america
i i learned how to eat cheeseburger or
mac and cheese and i never asked to put
the new ground chili on my burger or mac
and cheese so
maybe it's time for people to learn how
to eat
the right curries without asking for me
to turn it down or add
you know carrot or celery or whatever
in my curries because that's not not the
right thing to do
after the river prawn soup we moved to a
duck salad with kefir leaves and dried
chilis
then this delicious crab fried rice with
scallion and egg
what is in this this is so good the egg
and pickle mustard green
okay that's very simple that's my
mother's cooking she will
cook all vegetables with eggs they go
with everything this goes with
everything
next a colossal crab curry served in a
house-made
velvety curry powder sauce maybe our
favorite
i'm glad i'm making somebody very happy
this morning
you are velvety is a good word for it it
is a great texture
yes what makes it different is we use
chinese celery
that you just had to bite into it and
the flavor of chinese celery cut
with the curry powders so the first bite
i had it didn't have the chinese celery
in it
and the second one it did and it makes
all the difference yes that was followed
by steamed bronzino with a lime and a
thai
chili broth phuket style crab meat curry
served with rice noodles cucumber
cabbage and long beans
there aren't many places in america
where you can get this without me and my
staff no because we're not going to be
there so only at colorado
i love it all right next you ready yeah
i'm ready so you're going to be a little
bit more adventurous yeah sure
okay stinky beans with toasted ground
chicken curry and shrimp paste ooh
stinky bean
yes that's what my wife calls me
[Laughter]
this is called homesick edition because
i miss home so much i have not been home
in a year
so i created more dishes that could
bring me closer to home
and so what is the stinky bean this is
the bean this is the thing yes stinky
bean
is the kind of fruit that we use widely
in southern cooking
is available in rainy season it's a very
unique flavor
it's really good for your body we
finished with
coconut rice chicken curry and cabbage
there is one
prominent thai dish you will not find on
this table
and that you will not find sun toren and
serving in her restaurant
you don't have pad thai on your menu we
do on takeout
not in the dining room people ask for it
and you say what i smile
i smile a lot because i want my
restaurant to be thai fried dining
where do you hope you can take thai food
moving forward
what i would like to take thai food
forward is the
perception that thai food or ethnic food
should be inexpensive we should move
past that
you've convinced me i did yes
maybe the big giant shrimp convinced you
not me
all of it and just for you guys i have
lots incredible dumplings bird dumplings
it takes her three hours to make